[تصفيق]
شيخ الاسراف ادي الشوبكي حرا طليقا
لم تعر سلطات الاحتلال اي اهتمام لامراضه
المزمنه التي اصيب بها خلال سبعه عشر عاما
قضاها داخل الاسره فقد نقلته لساعات من
سجن عسقلانه الى حاجز ترخوم العسكريه
جنوبي الخليلا ليفرج عنه منه هناك في
محاوله لتنغيص عليه طبعا
امام ضريح الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل ياسر
عرفات في رام الله اكد الشوبكي رغم كبر
سنه عزمه مواصله مسيره رفيق دربه النضالي
والثوري وفاء للشهداء والاسرار وسنواصل
الطريق اللي ابو عمار رسمها وبداها احنا
حنكمل المشوار حنكمل المشوار مهما كلف
التمن
وارواحنا رخيصه
امام وطننا امام شعبنا
اللواء الشوبكي الذي استقبل بحفاوه
الابطال في رام الله اعتقله الاحتلال عام
2006 واتهمه بالوقوف وراء تهريب سفينه
اسلحه عرفت بكارين اي عام 2002 كونه كان
يشغل في ذلك الوقت منصب رئيس الدائره
الماليه المركزيه العسكريه التابعه لاجهزه
الامن الفلسطينيه
الحكومه الفلسطينيه رحبت بالافراج عن
الشوبكي واكدت انها ماضيه في مساعيها
لنشره الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال ولن تكتمل
فرحتنا الا بتحرير كافه اسرار البواسل
الذين يخوضون معركه الحريه والكرامه
والعصيان في مواجهه البطش والتنكيل
والاجراءات الاجراميه
اسرع حريه اكثر من اربعه الاف وسبعمائه
اسير داخل المعتقلات الاسرائيليه يخوضون
منذ نحو شهر خطوات العصيان ضد اجراءات
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايتامار بن
جبير واداره مصلحه السجون واكدت هيئه
الاسرى العليا ان خطواتها التصعيديه
مستمره وصولا الى الاضراب المفتوح عن
الطعام في اول ايام رمضان للضغط على
الاحتلال للعدول عن تلك الاجراءات
التعسفيه تبقى فرحه الاسير المحرر فؤاد
الشوبكي منقوصه لما تركه خلفه من فصول
معاناه يعيشها الاسرى داخل المعتقلات
الاسرائيليه معاناه تنذر بتفجر الاوضاع
الامنيه داخل السجون وخارجها في ظل
استمرار حكومه الاحتلال في فرض اجراءات
الانتقاميه بحقهم سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره
رام الله فلسطين